america's schools are in the final weeks
before winter vacation and they will
tell you they need a break many of them
still face unprecedented shortage of
teachers and staff denver school
district with more than 90 000 students
and not enough teachers recently shut
down for a day just to let everybody
catch their breath
janet chameleon shows us how educators
across the country are taking on
multiple roles and they are feeling
overwhelmed
you do have some stuff on your desk go
ahead and finish up you might find gail
ortiz in the classroom teaching third
grade awesome you guys great job or on
the playground supervising recess let's
line up guys so glad you're here but
neither is her primary job at barnum
elementary in denver where officially
she heads the school your title is
principal but what are you doing right
now
i am principal
assistant principal
teacher
paraprofessional i cover classes
luxury says 2d
i
do
everything that needs to be done denver
is facing a critical shortage of
teachers due to illness anxiety over
covid and those leaving the profession
all together what's the stress level
like it's pretty high even though our
staff comes in with a smile
even though they do what they need to do
they're feeling it that's why the
hallways went dark recently
superintendent alex marrero closing the
district's more than 200 campuses for an
unprecedented mental health day every
teacher has become a social work and
guidance counselor they weren't trained
to do so right so everybody is now going
well beyond the scope of mathematics or
literacy
and they're asked to do a little bit
more that they haven't received the
training for
marrero says they used to have 1200
substitutes to help more than 800 quit
during the pandemic
it's not just here in denver burnout is
fueling shortages of teachers and staff
like bus drivers and cafeteria workers
in schools all across the country a
principal in newark new jersey is also
the morning crossing guard
and in las vegas principal joseph ue
without janitors vacuums classrooms and
scrubs floors last month there hasn't
been one day that i haven't had to ask
my staff to fill in the gaps
some schools have gone back to remote
learning or extended holiday vacations
to manage you have a long way to go
until
may or whenever school is out you know
what's the scariest part when you hear a
teacher saying it feels like march
to have that type of fatigue early on in
the fall it's scary you guys did great
did you mark with your red markers at
barnum elementary volunteers like grace
signs keep the doors open i try to do
once a week a helpful but temporary
band-aid for a profession with much
deeper wounds
for cbs mornings i'm janet schamelian in
denver
[Music]
well i don't know anybody whether you
have children or don't have children
that doesn't have newfound respect for
teachers yeah because they're asked to
do a little bit more and they're not
getting paid a little bit more either to
do all the things that they're doing and
they're not trained for it i mean is ms
ortiz says she's not only the principal
she's also a teacher i mean when you go
to detention she's probably sitting
right there you go to check out a
library book she's a librarian
it's really we're asking a lot of our
teachers and it shouldn't be like that
as we do our holiday shopping consider
the teachers that's right and i'll
encourage you when you see them a simple
handshake or even a hug followed by a
thank you will go a long way please
don't buy your teacher a mug
let
it's important i remember every teacher
in my life at every grade there was at
least one that stays with me they're
super girls that's for sure exactly
right